Militärflugplatz Fürstenfeldbruck bei
München dieses Bild zeigt eines der
größten disaster der Nachkriegszeit
damals kommen hier auf dem
Militärgelände neun Israelis um die
vorher gekidnappt wurden und drei
Terroristen
1972 da gibt es im September die
Olympischen Spiele und sie enden in
einer furchtbaren Katastrophe damals
wird die GSG9 gegründet denn der Einsatz
der Polizei hier ist gründlich schief
gegangen wir sprechen mit dem Kommandeur
der GSG9 Ulrich halloen
[Musik]
Tag ich war verbindndungsoffizier des
Bundesgrenzschutzes beim Minister ich in
eine Art Adjudant würde wir heute sagen
nicht und ich war kurz bevor ich hierher
kam war ich in bei der NATO in mün in
Rom und gen hat mich dann zurückgeholt
nicht von diesem NATO Lehrgang und äh
äh als ich hierher kam war ich entsetzt
über das was ich was ich dort gesehen
habe nicht also äh für ein ich ich war
immer taktisch derhr interessiert
während meiner gamten Laufbahn
äh wenn irgendwo eine Übung gemacht wde
dann hieß es immer das macht der Wegner
nicht und deswegen äh habe ich die
Vorbereitung der Polizei hier für diese
für diesen Einsatz habe ich für
unmöglich gehalten jetzt muss man
denjenigen die die damalige Zeit nicht
erlebt haben sagen das war eine Zeit in
der man die klassische antiterrorarbeit
so noch gar nicht kannte zumindest nicht
in der Form wie wir sie jetzt nach
2001 den Angriffen in den in New York
kennt das waren ja normale
Schutzpolizisten zum Teil die hier
schüzen soll da haben sie natürlich
völlig Recht die die waren natürlich
nicht nicht dafür ausgebildet isten zu
bekämpfen da keine Frage nicht aber man
hätte vieles doch besser machen können
nicht wenn man alleine taktische
Grundbegriffe eben angewendet hätte eine
Beurteilung der Lage gemacht hätte und
ein und dann eine taktische Entscheidung
getroffen hat aber das alles fand ja gar
nicht statt sondern man man meinte man
müsste das sofort aus dem Ärmel
schütteln und ohne eine gewisse
Vorbereitung ohne die die Leute
vorzubereiten und und so weiter und so
weiter nicht und dann vor allen Dingen
was was mich also empört hat war in der
conol Straße dass man dort auch das
Publikum nicht ferng gehalten hat das
ist die der Ort an dem die geiselname
stattfand hier ist das passiert was wir
als schwachze Stunde der
Nachkriegszeit ja das ist richtig aber
die schwarze Stunde fing schon in der
kolestraße an nicht wie gesagt und hier
ist
natürlich kam das also dann zu dieser
Katastrophe nicht die die ich konnte mir
das gar nicht vorstellen ich stand oben
im Tauer mit dem Minister und wir haben
uns das wir haben das alles hautnah
erlebt nicht was ist hier wirklich
schief gegangen Fürsten ja es ist einmal
schief gegangen dass man es stand da
vorne
ja 100 m Entfernung von hier eine
Maschine der der lufthanser der eine 727
und das hatte man ja abgesprochen mit
den Terroristen dass die Terroristen
ausgeflogen werden sollten nicht und
bloß die Besatzung war gar nicht mehr da
die sind genommen ausgegangen weil sie
eben keine Opfer spielen wollten nicht
und dann kam es die Terroristen merkt
natürlich dass man sie
da betrogen hatte oder wie man es auch
nennen will und haben daraufhin sofort
das Feuer eröffnet nicht
als als sie merkten dass man sie hier in
eine Falle locken wollte aber das was
hier zur Verfügung stand war ja ein
sagen wir mal nicht ganz eller Rahmen es
soll hier fünf Schützen gegeben haben
die sollten die Terroristen erschießen
bzw überwältigen das ist aus der
Nachschau eine völlig amateurhafte
Aktion ja natürlich es fing schon damit
an dass die Anzahl der Terroristen ja
gar nicht bekannt war offensichtlich und
das das ist erst zu zu spät erkannt
wurde dass es mehr Terroristen waren
als als die Polizei eingesetzte
Scharfschützen hätte und bewegen können
dabei nicht und damit fingt der Spaß
schon an nicht und äh dann hat man also
kam es z einem Feuergefecht hier in dem
in dem Vorfeld des Tau und hier vorne
stand ja diese Hubschauber die die drei
Maschinen der des bundesgrandschutzes
und äh es kam dann
zu einem zu einem erheblichen
Feuergefecht wie gesagt der der Minister
und ich wir saßen da oben im
kommandeursraum und ich habe da den
Minister gesagt Herr Minister bitte sie
darum sofort volte Deckung zu nehmen und
wir haben es dann unter den Schreibtisch
gelegt weil es überall kam Einschläge
von von den aus den terroristischen
Waffen unter anderem fielen also so ein
paar glasschaben runter von einem von
einem Schrank dort und so weiter nicht
also sie hatten auch sie hatten
persönlich auch Angst um ihre Sicherheit
als sie na ja natürlich ich habe ang
Angst dass den Minister erwischen würde
Daum da nicht und das
K konnte ja wohl nicht nicht das dfte ja
wohl nicht passieren nicht und ich ich
habe dann dann dann kam es also
plötzlich zu einer Feuerpause
nach einem Feuergefecht das ungefähr so
10 Minuten gedauert hat
und in dieser Feuerpause passierte gar
nichts nicht ich ich konnte mir das
überhaupt nicht vorstellen ich ich habe
dann ich ich bin dann aus dem Raum raus
und bin die Treppe runtergegangen unten
lag eine Hundertschaft der
Bereitschaftspolizei und ich habe dann
den den hundcha Führer gefragt ich sag
sagen Sie mal wollen sie jetzt nicht
endlich mal was tun oder ihr müsst doch
Eingreifen jetzt ihr müsst doch
irgendwas tun holt doch die Überlebenden
aus dem Hubschrauber ne darfin sagte der
mir eine klassisch deutsche Antwort ich
habe keinen
Befehl die Terroristen sind vor allen
Dingen dadurch umgekommen dass eine
Handgranate explodiert ist in dem
hubchrauber wahscheinlich nicht nur eine
Handgranate sondern es waren mehrere
Handgranaten die geworfen wurden in die
Hubschrauber rein und die dann die
Hubschrauber
in Wand setzen
und und die die
Überlebenden wurden durch teilweise
durch die handgranatensplitter und durch
die Terroristen
selbst getötet nicht soll einer von den
Israelis mindestens umgekommen sein
durch Verletzungen der Lunge durch Rauch
das heißt man hat auch gar nicht richtig
reagiert obwohl man hätte reagieren
können und retten können eben man hätte
man hätte sofort einige sturmtrups
einsetzen K können die die an die
Hubschrauber angegangen werden und dort
die Überlebenden raus hätten rausholen
müssen nicht das äh wir haben das ja
später mal nachgespielt mit der GSG9
nicht und das das war für mich eine
unmögliche taktische situation ne Hans
Dietrich Genser mit ihnen unter dem
Schreibtisch sehr schnell mit ihnen
einig dass man eine Antiterroreinheit
Gründen muss das ist innerhalb ja fast
schon weniger Tage geschehen die
Gründung der gsgen ja das ist richtig
und
wei wie gesagt der Minister war selber
traumatisiert und und ich war auch
natürlich derart mitgenommen durch
dieser durch dieses Unvermögen und
diese unmöge unmögliche Vorgehensweise
der Polizei hier dass ich dem Minister
auf dem Rückweg nach München schon
gesagt habe im Auto ich sag das das darf
uns nicht normal passieren nicht wir
müssen etwas tun und wir müssen und er
war leichenblass und war sehr sehr
mitgenommen und da kam es ja dann zu
dieser unmöglichen Pressekonferenz sie
Erinn sich im ersten Teil hat man dann
erklärt alle geiselen sind gerettet und
was ich nachher als Falschmeldung erwies
und im zweiten Teil wurde dann alles
zugegeben der bayerische Innenminister
hat ja dann erklärt dass es zu diesem
fiasco gekommen war und ich habe dann
dem Minister gesagt wir müssen uns dazu
entschließen jetzt eine eine neue
Einheit aufzubauen nicht und er sagte ja
vielleicht beim bundesk nicht ich ich
habe nicht ich habe gesagt auf keinen
Fall beim Kriminalamt nicht sondern wir
wollen eine Truppe haben die man
zu jeder unter jeder Legende einsetzen
konnte nicht und er hat mir dann
zugestimmt nicht so kam es dann zum
Beschluss der Bundesregierung noch in
München nicht
zur Aufstellung der
GSG9 sie wurden Kommandeur ja und was
war ihr was war ihr erster Schritt was
mussten sie jetzt machen ich darf ich
darf ihn dazu sagen dass ich mich dass
ich gleich den Minister da gesagt habe
ich möchte ich bin so mitgenommen durch
diese Ereignisse hier in fürstenfeldbrg
und München ich möchte diese Einheit
kommandieren und aufbauen und
da sagt er da haben sich aber was das
vorgenommen aber sagt er ich stimme ihn
zu nicht und mein ja mein erster Schritt
war
äh dass ich
äh mir natürlich einige Offiziere
herausgesucht habe aus dem
Bundesgrenzschutz für die ich kannte und
denen gesagt habe wir machen jetzt mal
ein Brainstorming und versuchen
jetzt uns etwas vorzustellen was wie
diese Einheit aussehen würde es gab ein
Vorbild und das haben sie auch besucht
nämlich die Israelis die waren ja mitten
in einer Situation wo sie ständig damit
rechnen mussten und da haben sie sehr
viele Dinge kennengelernt die man auch
übertragen konnte ja das ist richtig
also das war natürlich der zweite Schut
nicht wie gesagt ich habe dann den
Minister vorgeschlagen das war ja keine
Selbstverständlichkeit dass ich nach
Israel gehen wollte und er sagt er
antwortete ich hö ihn heute noch sagen
sagt na da haben sich aber etwas
vorgenommen natürlich
war wusste ich dass die Israelis nicht
begeistert waren ausgerechnet einen
deutschen Offizier da zu empfangen und
und mit denen zu arbeiten aber ich ich
habe den ich habe den Israelis innerhalb
kürzester Zeit ich ich war fast ein
viertel Jahr dort ne fast 8 Wochen ja
etwas über etwas mehr als 8 Wochen und
ich habe den israelisten klar gemacht
dass wir nachdem ich zuerst nicht gerade
große Begeisterung hervorgerufen habe
als ich eintraf habe ich ihnen klar
gemacht wenn wir in Zukunft etwas gegen
den internationalen Terrorismus
erreichen wollen D müssen wir
zusammenarbeiten und deswegen bin ich
hier und das hat auch nachher
hervorragend geklappt ich ich habe sehr
viele Freunde heute in Israel und auch
ich war zich mal in Israel in der
Zwischenzeit und und die Israelis hatten
großes Vertrauen nachher zu mir ich bin
z.B von israelischen
generalstaschaff bei der Aktion peace
für Galilea eingeladen worden mit in den
Libanon zu gehen nicht und das sind
alles so Sachen die man ja nur mit
vertrauten Freunden machen kann was war
denn ihr Gefühl als sie nach Israel ging
sie haben gerade schon gesagt da kommt
ein deutscher da kommt jemand der zwar
von den Israelis was lernen will aber
das war ja nun ein sehr gespanntes
Verhältnis natürlich weil die haben in
der ersten in den ersten Tagen ich es
waren sehr bekannte Leute darunter die
und unter anderem ihut Barock ja ja und
die haben also in der ersten Zeit
überhaupt nicht mit mir gesprochen nicht
das
die waren so auf
Aversion weil eben nach ihrer Auffassung
die deutschen völlig versagt hatten und
ich habe ihnen dann klar gemacht denn
nach einigen Tagen haben wir uns mal
abends zusammengesetzt und ich habe ein
sehr kameradschaftliches Verhältnis dann
äh erreicht indem ich ihnen sagte wir
wollen zusammenarbeiten in Zukunft und
und das geht nur wenn ihr uns hilft
jetzt nicht und wenn wenn wir das
zusammen entwickeln ne her wigner als
sie nach Israel kommen zu den
kommandoeinheiten was können Sie von
denen ja quasi sofort übernehmen was
können Sie von denen lernen ja diese
unkonventionelle Kampfführung das das
war eigentlich das A&O was wir wir
konnten natürlich vieles nicht
übernehmen weil in Israel andere
Situation war da als in als in Deutsch
aber die UN konventionelle Kampfführung
die haben wir übernommen und die haben
wir auch in Deutschland dann weiter
ausgebaut so dass uns also praktisch
keine terroristische Bedrohung mehr mehr
überrascht hat das darf ich ganz offen
sagen um es mal allgemein zu festzulegen
sie haben ja selber dann auch in den
Büchern Richtung Mao etc stadtgerea
gelesen um auch zu verstehen wie
Terroristen denken natürlich das war
ganz wesentlich wie denken Terroristen
eigentlich nicht und so haben wir als
eine
der typischen Vorschriften der der
stadtgeriller die das Handbuch für die
stadtgeriller z.B von Carlos marigiller
das war eine ständige Vorschrift bei
uns als sie mit den Israelis zusammen
waren von denen Taktik
sich anschauen konnten was machte deren
spezielle Fähigkeit aus ja das war eben
diese unkonventionelle krampführung die
die das Vorgehen das richtete sich je
nach demem Ort wo die der terroristische
Überfall stattfand und genauso haben wir
das auch gemacht nicht dass wir
uns je nachdem wie die Lage war in an
dem entsprechenden Ort wo der
terroristische Überfall stattfand danach
haben wir uns gerichtet nicht und so und
danach sind wir vollgegangen nicht und
das hat sich bisher hundertprozentig
bewrt ne als es hier die gaselnah gab
und die so furchtbar beendete mit dem
Tod der israelischen
Geiseln da kam sie ja sicherlich auch
nach Israel mit dem Gefühl wir müssen
jetzt wieder was in Ordnung bringen was
bei uns schief gelaufen ist ja natürlich
das das war das das war praktisch der
Beginn dass ich mit den Israelis darüber
gesprochen habe habe ich ih versichert
wir tun alles dass so etwas in
Deutschland nicht noch mal passiert und
äh wir sind sicher
dass das ein ein neuer Anfang in der
Terrorismusbekämpfung in Deutschland ist
haben sie bei denen nicht
nur ja sagen wir mal Trauer sondern
vielleicht auch Wut auf die deutschen
gespürt ja das ist etwas überzogen
wahrscheinlich dargestellt aber
natürlich war man ärgerlich nicht über
diese ganze und der Trauer auch
natürlich über die
toten Kameraden und Mitkämpfer dort und
aber das war ja nur nicht mehr zu ändern
wir wir konnten ihn nur klar machen es
wird nicht mehr es wird ke kein zweites
München oder Fürstenfeld wo geben nicht
wir sorgen dafür nicht und wir wir und
deswegen
müssen wir in Zukunft auch weiterhin
zusammenarbeiten das war ganz wesentlich
ist da aus dieser Begegnung ein
Vertrauensverhältnis geworden ja
hundertprozentig das kann man da soow
sagen ich habe heute in der israelischen
Armee sehr viele Freunde angefangen vom
verteidungsminister wir wollen uns
jetzt mal nach München begeben und
einmal schauen wo im Grunde genommen
alles begann es begann nämlich sehr
fröhlich sehr locker ganz bewusst ein
offenes und freundliches Deutschland ja
das kann man aber sagen
ja september 1972 das waren fröhliche
Spiele so wurden sie annonciert und das
wollte man auch unbedingt in Deutschland
beweisen im Vergleich zu Berlin 1936
hier sollten fröhliche liberale offene
Spiele stattfinden wie war denn die
Vorbereitung auf mögliche
Sicherheitsprobleme ja das
es gab also mehrere Besprechungen vorher
wobei wie gesagt der Bund ja nur in
direkt beteiligt war nicht weil wir
haben ja keine Kräfte gestellt das hat
ja die bayerische
Staatsregierung verlangt dass die
bayerische Polizei das
macht wofür ich durchus Verständnis habe
aber
ich meine ich hatte auch Verständnis
dafür dass man
die die an die Olympische Spiele 36
gedacht hat und dass man nicht so so
also militaristisches
Schutz Gitter da auf bauen wollte oder
wie auch immer nicht so das ist völlig
verständlich aber was ich überhaupt
nicht verstanden habe ist da bei den
ersten Besprechungen kam das so raus äh
dass man z z.B einen völlig
unzureichenden Zaun um um das Ganze
Olympische Dorf gebaut hat der überhaupt
kein Hindernis war die Sportler sind
nachher während der Spiele am laufenden
Band über den Zaun gehüpft nicht und das
das hat überhaupt nicht gewirkt genauso
war war es ein unmöglicher Zustand das
fand ich also als ich dann mit gcher da
war dass dass die Polizeibeamten die in
einem fröhlichen blauen Anzug hier
auftratten überhaupt nicht bewaffnet
waren die konnten überhaupt nichts tun
die konnten nur weitermelden nicht das
war's dann nicht und das das war also
für eine
Großveranstaltung aus heutiger Sicht
natürlich völlig unö
aberus wir haben uns gesagt also
irgendwo ist da sind da riesen Fehler
drinne in dem Sicherheitskonzept aber es
gab ein Konzept und es ist offenbar auch
durchgespielt worden was passiert
eigentlich wenn es hier einen
Terroranschlag gibt der
Polizeipsychologe Sieber der damals
zuständig war hat das offenbar
durchgespielt den wollte aber niemand
hören der hat es nicht durchgespielt der
hat es vorgetragen er hat das
vorgetragen er hat auch eine geiselname
vorgetragen und und der der
Polizeipräsident der hat abgewinkt und
hat gesagt das interessiert niemand das
das brauchen wir auch gar nicht dabei
ist eigentlich wir haben eben darüber
gesprochen 9/11 2001 in den USA die
Anschläge das ist eine zesur sicherlich
für die weltweite Antiterror Bekämpfung
aber es gab die PLO es gab Anschläge es
gab Entführungen und eigentlich hätte
man sich darauf einstellen müssen ein
für sich hätte man sich darauf
einstellen müssen es gib wir haben ja
auch nationale Terroristen gehabt schon
hier in Deutschland nicht und man hätte
also schon was tun müssen das ist keine
Frage nicht als es war ein Riesenfehler
ist keine Frage als die Spiele begannen
war die Atmosphäre so wie man erhofft
hatte das war eine wundervolle bunte
Atmosphäre eine gute Stimmung
überall mit der Entführung bzw der
geiselname brach das plötzlich ab der
also wir waren alle sehr ganz be
geistert ich erinnere mich noch an die
Eröffnungsfeier und so weiter nicht das
war eine tolle Atmosphäre und so und
dann kam das
der in der Nacht vom vier zum FFT da da
passierte dieses dieser Terrorakt nicht
also der Überfall auf diese israelische
Olympia sind sie direkt informiert
worden hat man direkt mit Ihnen überlegt
was können wir jetzt tun was gab es nein
wir wir haben das also später erfahren
jetzt also Stunden später wir waren
inzwischen in der Stadt in einem Hotel
war das Genscher der der Stab von
Genscher und äh und wir haben das dann
erfahren und sind natürlich sofort ins
olympische Dorf gefahren und haben uns
dort mit Minister Merk und mit sch Herr
Schreiber getroffen und was da im
Einzelnen besprochen wurde weiß ich
nicht weil ich nicht dabei war nicht die
wollten nicht dass da jemand dabei war
aber aber eine der größten Probleme in
dem Gesamtzusammenhang ist die
Kommunikation nicht nur gewesen sondern
auch das was zwischen Bund und Ländern
passiert ist zwischen verschiedenen
Polizeieinheiten jetzt soll irgendwann
in nächster Zukunft all das mal
veröffentlicht werden das war lange
jetzt 40 Jahre unter Verschluss wird's
da noch Überraschungen geben nein das
glaube ich nicht also denn es war ja von
vorne rein klar das hatten die Bayern ja
damals auch verlangt die bayerische
Staatsregierung weil das ganze in
München stattfand die Olympischen Spiele
in München stattfand das die bayerische
Polizei
für das Sicherheitskonzept zuständig ist
und so wurde es auch gehandhabt nicht
und auch
der der Minister sagte mir da ich kann
mich noch entsinnen dass ich mal
gesprochen habe ja Kön könn sollt wir
nicht eine einige unser Einheiten
vielleicht jefalligen sagt nein nein wir
sind nicht zuständig wir sind ein
föderalistischer Staat und das ist in
erster Linie ein bayerisch eine
bayerische Sache da ich sag aber die
Bundesrepublik ist doch gefordert nicht
und ja es war halt so
war das Bewusstsein für die Gefahr nicht
hoch genug oder war
der Versuch dies nun besonders fröhlich
friedlich hier zu gestalten das
eigentliche beides beides würde ich
sagen es war natürlich auf der einen
Seite hatte man immer die Spiele von 36
im Auge oder noch in Erinnerung und
sagte wir sowas darf in Deutschland
nicht noch mal passieren nicht und äh
und dann hatte man eigentlich
auch so ich ich habe ein paar mal so
gefragt D mit habe mich mit
bayerischen polizeiam unterhalten die
sagten ja wir wissen ja gar nichts wir
haben ja keine keine Ahnung ob da
irgendwas sowas auf V zuk kommt nicht
als die Geiselnahme passierte ja als
klar war das ist eine dramatische Gefahr
die da entstanden ist es gab die ersten
Toten zwei Israelis
ist da die Stimmung umgeschlagen hat man
plötzlich gesagt oh wir müssen ganz
schnell etwas nachholen wir müssen die
Szenarien aus dem Aktenkoffer rausholen
und versuchen zu reagieren nein nein
nein wollte man erst verhandeln mit dem
den
und man wollte man wollte das Beste
draus machen wie man so sagt und aber
es die also es geschah nicht etwas das
also zu einer neuen Beurteilung der Lage
geführt hätte sondern sondern man sagt
jetzt wir werden wir werden mit der
Sache schon fertig werden nicht was
machte die Gefährlichkeit dieser
Geiselnehmer aus Abu Daud einer der
Drahtzieher der gesamten Aktion hat er
mal gesagt das war eigentlich ein
Himmelfahrtskommando wir hätten uns
jederzeit töten lassen bzw als
Selbstmordattentäter auftreten wollen
hab die PLO intelligent gut vorbereitet
in wir waren gut vorbereitet darüber
gibt es gar kein Zweifel man wusste zwar
einiges über über die Palästinenser man
wusste dass die PFLP schon einige
terroristische Anschläge äh irgendwo in
der Welt durch verübt hatte aber man
hatte überhaupt nicht dran gedacht dass
so etwas in in München passieren würde
wenn man das jetzt 40 Jahre danach
insgesamt mal betrachtet ist das etwas
aus dem die richtigen Lehren gezogen
worden sind nicht nur was die GSG9
anbetrifft doch ich glaube schon also
wir haben ja nicht nur die GSG9
aufgestellt danach äh als Nummer eins
Lehrer aus diesem äh aus diesem
furchtbaren Ereignis sondern es wurden
ja auch sofort die
terrorismusabteilungen der
Nachrichtendienste aufgebaut und auch
das Bundeskriminalamt hat eine
entsprechende Abteilung äh äh die sich
also mit dem Terrorismus beschäftigt sie
selber sind nach der Entführung und
Befreiung der Landshut über die wir
später noch sprechen dann sehr vielen
Ländern tätig gewesen als Berater
was hat das für Einblicke für sie nicht
nur als Berater sondern wir waren ja wir
haben auch in 13 Ländern ausgebildet
nicht und das hatte war natürlich von
großer Bedeutung nicht und
wir haben natürlich dadurch also auch
ein Wissen angesammelt nicht was heute
bei der GSG
noch zu Buche schlägt ist keine Frage
die gg9 ist heute eine der besten
Spezialeinheiten der Welt ohne
über ohne zu übertreiben mm was sind die
Anforderungen in anderen Ländern was
mussten sie möglicherweise auch doort
erst einmal ja als Grundlage vermitteln
ist das Bewusstsein in allen Ländern in
denen sie tätig waren so wie sie das
hier vorgefunden haben es ist ein
Unterschied ob sie mit Europäern zu tun
haben und oder mit araben mit Arabern
nicht wobei man auch mit
Arabern ziemliche Erfolge erzielen kann
nicht äh wenn man sie dazu bringt ähm
bestimmte Lehren zu akzeptieren nicht
und
äh bestimmte Vorgänge eben
so durchzuführen wie wie man das eben
beibringt nicht wir müssen noch mal
sprechen über die konkrete Situation die
sich damals ergab bei der Geiselnahme
und auch dann einen Sprung machen in die
5 Jahre später Geiselnahme der
landzot ja wir stehen im Olympiadorf in
der conollistraße hier waren die Geiseln
hier wurden sie festgehalten von den
Terroristen
m es hat während der Verhandlungen
groteske Szenen gegeben also grotesk war
z.B die Tatsache dass hier ganz viele
Kameras aufgebaut waren von
internationalen Fernsehanstalten die die
Bilder nicht nur hier gezeigt haben
sondern den Terroristen auch selber
völlig unverständlich ja also ich für
mich
war das also ein Horror als ich das
gesehen habe ich habe das auch dem
Minister gesagt ich sage wie wie kann
man sowas zulassen nachdem ich erfahren
hatte dass die die die Polizei jetzt
Aktion startet nicht und ich sage man
man kann doch nicht eine taktische
Maßnahme vor den Augen der
Weltöffentlichkeit durchführen die die
mit Sicherheit dann schief geht nicht
das ist keine Frage und das das das war
für mich völlig unverständlich und wir
haben das ja später dann noch mal
nachgespielt mit der GSG9 und natürlich
anders war das damals was sie dann durch
spieltelt haben erfolgreich das wäre
erfolgreich geworden das ich mE man kann
das nie sagen das ist ist ja eine
äh eine Annahme nicht denn
äh wir können auch nicht sagen dass das
ohne Verluste abgegangen wäre aber es
wäre erfolgreicher gewesen darüber gibt
es gar keinen Zweifel wir haben
Polizisten auf diesen Bildern immer
wieder gesehen die in Trainingsanzügen
hier rumliefen und den Eindruck machten
sie wissen gar nicht so genau was sie
hier wollen und
wozu Sie die Befehle haben ja sind hier
auf dem Dach gewesen hier unten herum
gelaufen das machte einen sehr sehr
amateurhaften Eindruck ja das war auch
der der
Ansatz war auch
amateörhaft so kann man eine Aktion ein
Sturm eines Objekts nicht durchführen
das ist darüber gibt es gar kein Zweifel
und war völlig ich konnte es gar nicht
glauben als ich das gesehen habe für die
Fernsehteams und die diese Kameraleute
und so weiter nicht und und dann diese
versuchten Aktionen der Po
nicht mit Teil teilweise völlig
hilflosen Polizeibeamten die sie auch
nicht wohl fühlten keine Frage es hat
immer
wieder den Hinweis gegeben israelische
Kommandos hätten bereit gestanden hätten
helfen können hätten eingesetzt werden
können Bundesregierung hat das abgelehnt
ja das muss man auch
verständlich gewisses Verständnis haben
ich meine es
äh war se nach dass die Israelis das
angeboten haben darüber gibt es gar
keinen Zweifel aber die Bundesregierung
und das hat mir auch der Minister noch
mal klar gemacht sagte wir konnten nicht
zustimmen aus den Gründen der
Souveränität der Bundesrepublik würde
man das heute noch mal so
machen mit Sicherheit würde man heute
die eine Möglichkeit der Zusammenarbeit
finden ne denn israelische Kommandos mit
denen sie zusammen trainiert haben haben
ihnen gesagt wenn wir ein Problem hätten
GSG9 wäre eine Truppe
jamenariten das ist eben der Unterschied
zu damals
ähm es hat ein Gerücht gegeben man hat
ja immer wieder gesagt es gab keine
deutschen Spezialtruppen ja ein Gerücht
gegeben dass der Bundesnachrichtendienst
eine solche Spezialtruppe hatte ist da
was dran nein das die diese Truppe diese
sogenannte stay behind Geschichte die
kommt immer wieder hoch und aber die
Truppe war überhaupt nicht geeignet für
für ein antiterroreinsatz
und wie weit sie überhaupt existent war
damals möchte ich bezweifeln also ich
ich wusste nicht davon ich auch der
Minister wusste nicht davon woher kommt
dieses Gerücht ja das ist haben eine
Leute aufgebracht die sich da
offensichtlich in zne setzen wollten
also sie gehen nicht davon aus dass da
wirklich was dran war 5 Jahre nach dem
disaster hier in München ihr vielleicht
größter persönlicher und beruflicher
Erfolg die Erstürmung der zu den
mogadishchu wir haben alle Geiseln
befreit in der
Maschine was haben Sie damals gefühlt
denn 5 Jahre lang haben sie auch um die
GSG9 kämpfen müssen um den Fortbestand
ja sie haben es ja richtig gesagt 5
Jahre haben wir kämpfen müssen aber für
uns nicht nur für mich sondern auch für
meine Männer war das eine Bestätigung
dass wir richtig gelegen haben und es
war natürlich auch für mich ein
persönlicher
Triumph dass ich nicht falsch gelegen
habe und als ich auch der Regierung ja
einiges zugemutet
habe sie haben dann in den Folgejahren
eigentlich bis heute immer mal wieder
auch Situationen erlebt wo die GSG9
hätte erfolgreich eingesetzt werden
können wo sie aber nicht angefordert
worden es gibt die berühmte Geschichte
von der geiselname in
Gladbeck da sagt man heute im Grunde
hätte die GSG9 diese Situation bei
weitem besser bewältigen können gut dass
sie das erwähnen es war eine lange Zeit
war das ein ein echtes Problem die
Zusammenarbeit mit den Ländern nicht und
weil ein Teil der Länder sich geweigert
hat
sie wollten das alles alleine machen
nicht dai konnten sie es gar nicht sie
waren taktisch nicht in der Lage sie
waren ausrüstungsmäßig nicht in der Lage
und gerade diese diese Geschichte die
sie gerade erwähnt haben war für mich
ein Anlass auch der
Innenministerkonferenz noch mal zu sagen
da muss ich was ändern danach kam es ja
dann zu den Vereinbarungen mit mit den
Ländern das würde heute nicht mehr
passieren also kann man heute sagen die
GSG9 wird auch tatsächlich eingesetzt
wenn sie sinnvoll
ist wir stehen hier vor der Tafel dem
Angedenken an die Opfer in der conol
Straße wir werden den Terrorismus das
sagen sie auch selber wahrscheinlich
nicht ausrotten
können wird es weiter notwendig sein
solche Truppen wie die GSG9 zu haben und
werden wir sogar verstärkt darum kämpfen
ich meine natürlich werden wir den
Terrorismus nicht ausrutten können das
gibt immer Leute die
meinen sie müssten der Regierung zeigen
wo es lang geht nicht und mal anders
ausgedrückt aber gerade deswegen sind
sind heute Einheiten wie die
spezialeheiten wie die
GSG9 lebenswichtig für eine Demokratie
sie haben sehr gerne und oft von Pflicht
gesprochen sie sind jetzt 82 Jahre alt
jetzt muss man sich 83 Jahre alt jetzt
muss man sich schlicht mal fragen haben
Sie das Gefühl in ihrem Sinne und in
ihrer Vorstellung ihre Pflicht erfüllt
zu haben ich glaube schon ja also ich
ich meine für mich war die Zeit als
Kommandeur der gsk9 der Höhepunkt an
meiner Karriere das darf ich ganz offen
sagen und und das dieses preußische
Empfinden des
pflichtgefühls das das habe ich
eigentlich immer gehabt das wurde mir
von meinen Eltern natürlich mitgegeben
und und
ich war eigentlich ich war der
Überzeugung ich habe meine Pflicht getan
sie haben das manchmal tun müssen indem
sie auch nicht ihre Familie geschont
haben ihre Tochter hat sehr offen auch
gesagt es gab Probleme in der Familie
auch Ihre Frau hatte mal eine Zeitlang
sehr große Probleme mit dieser ja
Drucksituation sie waren ja auch
persönlich sehr gefährdet ja wie würden
Sie sich heute entscheiden natürlich ist
das immer eine ein ein Problem der der
Familien es ist ja nicht nur meine
Familie gewesen das S ja war auch die
Familien meiner Leute nicht und deswegen
haben wir uns gerade um diese Familien
auch besonders gekümmert und wir haben
immer einen Familientag gemacht im Jahr
nicht und wo wir uns um die Angehörigen
gekümmert haben weil sie verstehen
sollten was ihre Männer Taten und dass
das lebenswichtig war für für die für
die deutsche Demokratie
und dass die Aufgabe der G genau das
haben wir immer versucht den Angehörigen
beizubringen ist Leben zu retten und das
ist das A und O nicht sind sie mit 83
zufrieden mit dem was sie getan haben
ich glaube schon danke für das
[Musik]
Gespräch